New York Times investigative reporter
Jody Kanter joins us to discuss a
lessons learned from the hill hearing
she co-wrote the first story about
sexual harassment allegations against
Harvey Weinstein which fueled the me2
movement The Times won a Pulitzer Prize
for that reporting Jodi's also the CBS
News contributor and she joins us again
at the table boy Jody you look at that
video and it makes you wince you look at
a Nita Hills face and the questions that
she had to take and had to answer is
this a case of deja vu all over again
well here we are almost a year after the
me2 movement caught fire around the
world and it feels like we are returning
to the original Ground Zero of these
Supreme Court nomination hearings and
the question to watch for in the next
week is is this a repeat of the Anita
Hill dynamic which by the way neither
side wants right the Republican senators
don't want to look like clueless and
insensitive men grueling a woman they
may end up that way anyway and certainly
what dr. Ford's lawyers have suggested
is that she doesn't want to be subjected
to that kind of treatment either and of
course we all remember the Anita Hill
hearings and we were talking about them
that's all the nation could talk about
for weeks on end we seem to be in such a
fast-paced news cycle though I mean
remember the anonymous op-ed just a few
weeks ago no one's talking about that
now could that be one of the reasons
Republicans want to get this boat
through quickly hoping that the
storyline does change a week or two from
now or do you think this one sticks well
I think they have a lot of reasons for
wanting to do this very quickly but on
the other side dr. Ford's lawyers are
essentially arguing this needs to be
done in some sort of fair and sensitive
way now the question is what that really
looks like right it's like both sides
are kind of trying to make it up as they
go along
Anita Hill wrote in an op-ed piece that
that the committee has quote learned
little from the Thomas hearing much less
than more recently to movement how much
do you think things have shifted well I
think things have shifted considerably
in the last year and also in the years
since the Clarence Thomas confirmation
hearings for one thing this this entire
discussion is about an alleged incident
that took place in high school an
alleged violation that took place in
high school so it's real
interesting that we're now discussing
that kind of behavior on the public
stage I also think the response to
doctor for it is very different than it
was to Anita Hill there is she has been
attacked she has been threatened but
there's also been a lot of sensitivity
and sympathy and she's being hailed by
some people as a hero for coming forward
the thing we see again and again that
never seems to change is that it is so
hard for women to come forward and dr.
Ford is dr. Blay c42 someone who's
really struggled with the decision about
whether to go public or not she has a
lot of support and so does he and they
both tell very different stories we
should also point out just that she's
also getting death threats I mean yes
exactly I mean it's just a nasty
situation on both sides what are you
going to be looking for if both of them
did we know he's going to testify it
looks like she is - what should we be
looking for how do you determine who's
telling the truth here well the quote
here's my cautious prediction I think
it's possible that his testimony may be
even more dramatic than his and
certainly if there's any
cross-examination that may be true
because what we can basically see is
that she will get up and tell the same
story that she told to the Washington
Post which is a story that we already
know
however he has issued this kind of
sweeping blanket denial and there are a
lot of questions that are going to be
asked about him you know how familiar
were you in high school really this
party didn't happen at all the
allegation is that you were very drunk
if you were drunk how would you even
remember what happened anyway and he has
a friend there who admits he wasn't
really exactly will he be called - you
know he said the friend says allegedly I
should say this right the friend says he
doesn't want to speak up could it be
compelled to in some way etc etc so so
my cautious prediction because none of
us know what will happen in the next
week is that his testimony could be even
more riveting than hers
Jodi Kanter thanks so much for being
with us thank you